This isn't actually Paul Rudd.
It's an action figure of Paul Rudd.
And it's got a lot more detail than
the action figures you may be used to.
You've probably seen action
figures like this before.
It's based on a movie,
has some accessories,
and it kind of looks like the star.
I think?
Definitely not an exact resemblance.
Up until a few years ago,
action figures didn't really look
like their movie counterparts.
That changed when Hasbro introduced
its Photo Real technology in 2017.
Used on both its Marvel Legends
and "Star Wars" Black Series lines,
the technology allows the company
to create figures with faces that
look exactly like the
actor they're based on.
The figures begin like most others.
Things like accessories, outfits,
and points of articulation
are all planned out digitally,
and a basic sculpt and molds
of the figure are created.
Once we have a 3D sculpt that
we're in love with, that
matches our design spec,
it gets turned over to the model shop.
They will cast it, which is a process
of taking the files, growing the files,
taking those pieces,
casting them in rubber molds
so that we can make duplicates.
Narrator: Once the duplicates are made,
the process of making
this plain white figure
look just like its character can begin.
It starts with some pretty high-res photos
of the actor in costume.
The photos are provided by the studio.
In this case, Marvel,
which works with Hasbro
to make sure they get the photos
and angles they need.
But for something like "Star Wars,"
which didn't have lifelike
action figures in mind
when it began filming
more than 40 years ago...
So a lot of it kind of
relies on on-set photography,
especially for kind of getting some
of the character likenesses.
Really just being able to capture
every angle of the character,
every angle of the costume,
and really being able to accurately
recreate that in a digital sculpt.
Narrator: Once the
reference photos are chosen,
the real fun begins.
Dwight: We will take
these types of images,
and we'll send them
down to our model shop,
and they will take these
into different programs,
cut them apart, and reconfigure them.
I can show you that we use
our 3D modeling software.
And in here, we take
all the photo reference
that they've given us, zoom
in, get all these details.
We create multiple layers,
and we just kinda go in here,
and we start refining different
shapes, different colors.
Narrator: The sculptors
use the reference photos
and the already-crafted head sculpts
to digitally recreate the actors
and paint their face
onto the digital sculpt.
When I get the head in, it's actually
just like a plain, blank, white head.
And then from there, I add all the colors.
I'm just constantly going back and forth
between the reference and the sculpt
and painting, and we try to recreate it.
Narrator: The artist might add some blush,
refine the eyes, increase
the overall saturation -
basically making sure any
detail in the actor's face
is mirrored in the figure.
Add shading to underneath
Harrison Ford's scar,
so we make sure that
comes out in the sculpt.
Anywhere that we feel like
we want to accentuate.
His brow line, he kinda
has a serious look,
so I put some shading in there so
when it prints, it really
accentuates the sculpt.
Narrator: Once the face is finished,
it's printed onto the head sculpt.
Finally, the sculptor will assemble
the different parts of the figure
and paint the non-Photo Real parts.
Tony: We'll prime this
out, the whole figure.
We'll base out the figure.
Then we'll start doing
all the hand-painting.
All the details.
We've got our green here.
So just going in, hand-painting
all those details.
And then by the end of it,
we've got a fully painted model.
Narrator: Because the process is so new
and secretive, there were a few things
Hasbro couldn't show us.
But once the model is complete,
Hasbro, its manufacturing partners,
the licenser, and the
actor all work together
to make sure everyone loves
both the figure and the
packaging it will come in.
And a few months after
everyone signs off on it,
it's ready for store shelves.